- Oh God, it hurts.
- Oh my God! Aghh!
(laughing)
- I think I'm shedding a
little tear right here.
- You still got it in there.
- A thug tear though.
A thug tear.
(upbeat music)
- Today we're going to
be waxing our nose hairs.
- From what I thought, I didn't
have that much nose hairs
but, by asking a few people in the office,
I found out I have some.
- I don't think I have hairy nostrils,
I think I'm very clean.
- Should I look and see?
- I've removed other body hair.
- But not nose hair?
- But not nose hair.
- I'm nervous about ripping
hairs out of my nostrils
but I'm excited to rip the
and not have them there anymore.
- I'm scared that something's gonna happen
like an episode of Grey's Anatomy
where like, "it's not
actually a nose hair,
it's like a nerve-ending that's connected
to my brain and then I go into
paraphilitic shock.
- I am here for this and I am about it.
I have a trimmer, I've tried razor blades,
I've tried plucking it.
And nothing works.
So if this can be like,
the thing, then I'll try it.
(upbeat music)
Well, because I'm a five-year-old boy
I immediately laughed when
I read the word 'Nads.'
- First off, I love
that it's called 'Nads.'
- I was literally just thinking that.
- Because I feel like dads have nose hairs
like nads.
- My mind went to gonads.
- What's gonads?
- Ya balls.
- It's like if you took
a small little sucker,
stuck it in your nose and
pulled out your nose hairs,
that's this.
- The main thing that I've
noticed on here, it says,
it's painless.
I don't believe that, at all.
- So you can do your nostrils,
the hair on top of your
nose, and your unibrow,
which is super cute,
'cause it's like, three-in-one.
- This is the best part.
(laughing) - Facial hair protectors.
- Wait, am I in jeopardy of waxing off my
facial hair by accident?
(beep)
- Alright, let's see.
- Wait, you need to wear one too.
- I kind of want to wax
off if I have a mustache.
- I need the old-timey one.
I need the one that goes up here.
I don't want the biker gang mustache.
(laughs)
- So we're gonna start.
Are you ready?
- Should we taste it?
- No!
- So we have to heat up the
wax, it says for two minutes
we throw this full jar in there.
- Never allow the wax
to boil, overheated wax
can cause serious burns.
We're in danger.
- First things first, I'm putting this on.
I'm not messing around.
- Do I need to sign a
waiver before I do this?
- It is important to
time this with a watch
for at least 90 seconds.
- We're supposed to dip it in, like that,
and then pull it out like this, turn it.
- Like I'm making a caramel dessert.
- Yeah, kind of, sure.
- I am not well.
- One for you. One for me.
Cheers.
- I feel like it's going to make me pee
on myself or something.
- Why are you gonna pee?
Why is peeing involved in this?
- 'Cause the pain.
(time ticking)
- Oh my God.
(timer dings)
- Give us a three-count.
One.
- Two.
- Three.
- Whoa! (screaming and laughing)
- Ohh! Oh my God!
- Why is it stuck?
(laughing)
- Holy hell!
- That didn't work.
- Okay, I'm gonna do it again.
- Consider me shook.
- Look you can make full
eyelashes out of these.
(wretching)
- One, two, three.
- Naaaddsaa!
There's so much in there.
God!
There we go. Oooh.
- Damn.
You have, like, a new fur coat.
- I gotta do the other one.
(laughing)
Oh my God, you gotta see
what came out of your nose!
- How do I look now?
- You still have a lot in there.
- God dangit!
- Let's talk about it.
- I don't know if I wanna talk about it.
- I learned that I have just as many hairs
in my nose as I thought I had
and now they're all gone.
- It's satisfying.
If you like popping pimples,
or, plucking hairs, it's great.
It's like painting a wall,
you see results immediately.
- I learned actually the opposite.
I thought I trimmed, but to the contrary,
I have a lot.
- I would totally do it again.
I would love to pull
Vaughn's out once a week.
(sniffs in)
- I feel like I can breathe better.
- How often do I have to do this?
- I mean, for you, once a week, minimum.
- Overall, it was a pleasant experience.
Didn't hurt that much, only
took like three minutes tops,
and got a lot of my little
dudes out of my nose.
- Thanks Nads. (ding)
♫ How come every time you
come around my nose hairs
♫ Nose hairs, nose hairs all around
(laughs)
- [Man] We did not plan that whatsoever.
(funky music)